people in ukraine are waking up to
another day of war and fear loud
explosions have been heard in the
capital kiev over the last few hours
there was no breakthrough at talks
between ukrainian and russian officials
yesterday more meetings are set for
today one of the issues on the agenda is
expected to be the devastating situation
in the city of mariupol
in a matter of seconds they have to run
for their lives
then the bombardment begins
this is what life looks like in mario
paul a city under siege by russian
forces
we have no information at all we know
nothing
it looks like we are living in a deep
forest they should have told us
something at least about what's going on
and where
heavy shelling has destroyed homes
supermarkets and hospitals in marielle
poll
residents have been without food water
and electricity
more than 2 000 people have died here
since the war began
footage from above
shows the scale of destruction across
the city
which is completely surrounded by
russian forces
on monday a first convoy of civilians
was able to escape mario paul
the first evacuation in two weeks of
russian bombardment
but an aid convoy trying to reach the
city was reportedly blocked by russian
forces
this footage was released by the russian
defense ministry
they say 200 buses have been prepared
for the evacuation of mario paul
residents
and aid is on its way
car convoys with humanitarian cargo were
promptly formed and immediately sent
the first convoy has already arrived in
mariopol and delivered 450 tons of
medical supplies essentials and food
meanwhile fighting on the ground
shows no sign of abating
our reporter matthias berliners in
kievan joins us now for more matthias
let's start with mario paul people there
now risking their lives to escape they
weren't able to use a humanitarian
corridor so what does that say about the
level of people's desperation there now
well what we've seen these people these
160 cars that have escaped they use the
humanitarian corridor and the uh
and it was possible to escape because
the season fire held for some time but
then shelling began again i think it
would be very difficult to get out of
the city without any uh corridor without
any agreement right now because the city
is completely surrounded and fighting
has been going on around the around the
city now the situation in there is dire
it's been more than 10 days that people
have had no food no water no medicine no
electricity we also have spa
scarce information from there because uh
mostly the phones are down or the
the mobile network so uh it's a it's a
very dire situation and we're hearing
that thousands have died already
and in kiev matthias where you are we
understand there have been more
explosions near the center can you tell
us more about what's happening there
yeah there were several explosions at
night some of them quite loud we heard
them here and uh it seems that again
residential buildings have been hit uh a
ten-story building was on fire and
another nine-story building has been hit
also on the north in the northern part
of the city and it seems that russia is
intensifying it's uh it's shelling off
the city and its bombings of the city uh
in the sky has been
had had been spared we have to say for
some time of heavy uh bombings after
initial initially some uh bombs if you
remember the tv tower bomb hit the hit
the city but uh then it was a bit calmer
and now this has
resumed and
we have visited one of these buildings
these residential buildings that have
been hit by a shell yesterday
yaroslav nafilloninka has been sitting
outside her apartment since the early
morning hours she's waiting for someone
to pick her up after the apartment she
has been living for decades was shelled
overnight
this is it
one room another small one and a kitchen
that's what it was
it was 5 am when a shell hit the house
there was a loud bang
and then immediately some kind of white
smoke that burnt in the eyes and the
throat
and then i heard the firefighters in the
corridor saying don't go out the
staircase is gone
so they had me climb down on a
firefighter's ladder
we are at the northern edge of kiev and
this apartment building was fired upon
from outside of the city from the
russian positions north of kiev
cleaning up some of the debris but it's
hard to imagine people will ever be able
to live here again
authorities are saying that at least one
person died in the attack many more have
lost everything they had
those who can still access their
property are trying to secure their
belongings
yaroslavna is 83 years old this is the
second war she has experienced her early
childhood memories are of world war ii
i feel very bad
i'm tired my head hurts badly
why do i have to live through this
i just want some rest
a relative is on his way to pick her up
then she will have to start all over
again
just a heartbreaking story matthias and
surely not the only one
now talks between ukraine and russia are
resuming today do ukrainians like
yaroslavna in your piece have anything
to hope for do you think
well
she has told me that she doesn't
understand why it's impossible to uh
find a solution to this but and that's
probably what most uh people here uh see
because of course none of them have
access to the these talks we have heard
the ukrainian side uh saying that they
are carefully more optimistic about a
possible solution or or a ceasefire
being negotiated
as they feel that the russians are
looking for a way out that they have
miscalculated but of course this
messaging is also part of the tactics so
we don't really know what we know is
that their official positions are very
far apart from each other ukraine
wanting uh to keep its sovereignty and
wanting russian troops out of the
country whereas russia wants ukraine to
demilitarize as they call it to
factually give up its
sovereignty and its ability to defend
itself
matthias thank you for that matthias
building a dw correspondent in kiev
let's turn to dw russia analyst
constantine egert now constantine we
heard a little bit there from matthias
but from what you're hearing how are the
talks going from the russian perspective
well i think that the russian
perspective is uh very much dependent on
one man vladimir putin and we do not
have an indication that his any plans to
change
uh his plans on onslaught on ukraine
however i think the fact that at least
some humanitarian corridors
were left unharassed
during the previous day
shows that there is
basically a desire to well show some
flexibility
the extent to which that was ordered by
putin or was the initiative of the local
commanders remains to be seen my
suspicion will be that there is a
certain exhaustion uh
among the russian troops and among
actually the commanders who see that
they are going nowhere with this
campaign and so i suppose that what we
see is a general um
how should i put it decentralization
of command in ukraine that usually means
that local commanders uh will take uh
the initiative and do things that uh
that maybe in other circumstances they
wouldn't do definitely there
quite a bit of steam is out of this
invasion
constantine last night a journalist with
the country's state-run broadcaster
stormed the main news program and she
was holding a sign that read no war stop
the war don't believe the propaganda
they're lying to you here
she was quickly arrested and she hasn't
been reachable since but before she was
arrested she uh posted a video on social
media let's take a listen to what she
said
in the last years unfortunately i've
been working with kremlin propaganda on
channel one and i feel very much ashamed
of that i am very ashamed that i allowed
such lies on tv i allowed the
brainwashing of the russian people we
did not say anything in 2014 when it all
started we did not take to the streets
and protest when the kremlin poisoned
navalny we silently watched this
inhumane regime and now the entire world
has turned away from us
10 more future generations won't wash
out the shame of this fresh recital war
a truly courageous act given the harsh
punishments uh constantine
we've been hearing from day one of this
invasion that russians just aren't
getting the full picture of this war is
that changing now
well i think as far as the state media
is concerned no they nothing changed at
all and uh this action is very brave
actually i have to say that in 90 second
in 19 seconds video uh miss
pressed all the right subscribe i think
it was such a politically succinct
message uh that actually lots of russian
politicians can't formulate it better um
i suppose that though this shows that
uh there there is definitely something
bubbling under and i think that lots of
people
are
having second thoughts now uh i don't
know when it's going to burst into the
open but as is usually in russian
history
there is always some event which seems
to be completely irrelevant that
provokes an avalanche a political
collapse and this is what may happen in
such circumstances and i suppose that
lots of people now are having second
thoughts including by by the way at the
top just uh just
around the time that uh this courageous
producer at state tv stage erection uh
another former high-level functionary
deputy prime minister vorkovich who is
currently head of the international
chess federation uh made an interesting
statement to statement to him to an
american website mother jones which said
he pities the ukrainian people he feeds
the russian people war is horrible
basically it was a very mild message
he's a former state bureaucrat uh but
still he is in russia he's a former high
stake state functionary and even he
seems to start disagreeing i suppose my
suspicion rebecca will be hearing more
such voices probably initially quite
cautious uh
in the coming in the coming days uh my
experience of 1989 1991
shows that this does not happen
like like like a snap thing it goes on
for some time before it becomes
something more acceptable let's probably
hope for that
all right constantine thank you very
much for that constantine egert
the white house says high ranking u.s
and chinese officials have held seven
hours of intense talks on the fighting
in ukraine in the meeting in rome the
u.s raised concerns about china's
possible support to russia following its
invasion white house press secretary jen
sarki said the chinese side was warned
there will be consequences if it
provides assistance to moscow what we
have conveyed and what was conveyed by
our national security advisor in this
meeting is that should they provide
military or other assistance that of
course violates sanctions or
or supports the war effort that there
will be significant consequences but in
terms of what those specifics look like
we would coordinate with our partners
and allies to make that determination
here's a look at some other developments
in the ukraine conflict un secretary
general antonio guterres has warned of
the potential for nuclear war over
ukraine guterres stated that the
prospect of nuclear conflict once
unthinkable is now within the realm of
possibility he urged russia to stop its
invasion of ukraine and pursue diplomacy
instead
ukraine has denied launching a strike on
the separatist held city of donetsk
after russia accused it of killing 23
civilians russian officials said ukraine
has committed a war crime a ukrainian
military spokesperson said the rocket
was clearly of russian origin
germany has announced its beefing up its
air force with dozens of u.s made f-35
stealth fighters they'll be replacing
germany's fleet of tornado fighter
bombers which are currently the only
planes in the german air force certified
to carry nato nuclear weapons germany's
air force commander said russia's
actions in ukraine left no alternative
germany's bundesvara have been flying
these tornado jets for 40 years they are
still operational albeit aging but are
due to be retired in 2030.
tornadoes allowed germany to fulfill its
commitment to nato by delivering
american nuclear weapons in case of need
but new aircraft are now needed
after carefully considering all options
on the table i have decided to start
procuring f-35 jets to fulfill our
nuclear sharing obligations
the f-35 is considered the most modern
fighter jet in the world it can carry
u.s nuclear weapons and its design and
coding make it difficult for radar to
detect
i think we're sending the right signal
but we've chosen a system that's
available on the market to accelerate
the modernization of our armed forces
choosing the f-35 should speed up this
process another option is to upgrade the
europe-made euro fighter jets so they
too could carry u.s nuclear weapons but
that would probably take too long
the bundeswehr will continue to use and
buy european fighter jets but the
biggest purchase will now be of aircraft
from the us
military expert stefan baez says this
marks a pivotal change
the recent discussions about defense and
security policy make clear that the
german way of always wanting to develop
something itself may take far too much
time so buying something off the shelf
may be the quickest solution
[Music]
with its decision to purchase the f-35s
germany is embarking on a new path
for now the bundesvara is no longer
pursuing ambitious development projects
and instead buying what's on the market
even if this means greater dependence on
the u.s